so Christmas is always a really special
time for the royal family and where they
do traditionally come together and that
has always been at Sandringham and my
understanding is that King Charles III
is going to follow his mother's
tradition and host a family Christmas at
Sandringham this year Well Harry and
Megan have been invited for Christmas
but it's our understanding that they
won't be coming over to the UK they will
be spending the holiday season in
California well it was always the king's
intention to hit the ground running and
I think we've absolutely seen him do
that he's traveled tirelessly around the
country he's preparing for a series of
Tours both before his coronation on May
the 6th and after that coronation so he
is really sort of putting down the
markers of his new Reign he's wasted no
time in getting to work it's no
coincidence that a really important
decision in making Princess Anne and
Prince Edward councilors of state so
that they can stand in for him in his
absence was incredibly significant he
hasn't stripped Andrew and Prince Harry
of their roles but by having two new
councilors of State he's got Anne and
Edward to deputize for him when he's
away and I think we can expect him to be
a way a fair bit well I think it is
going to be frustrating possibly quite
um upsetting for Prince Harry and Prince
Andrew knowing that they've essentially
been demoted I mean the King has been
diplomatic I think in not stripping them
of their roles as councilors of state
but that essentially means that Charles
is not going to be using Andrew or Harry
as substitute and I think that's just
another probably quite painful reminder
for Harry that he's willing to be out of
the royal family people should expect
the real me in this and probably the me
that they've never gotten to know
certainly not in the past few years
where everything is through the lens of
the media as opposed to okay it's me I'm
just excited to be myself and talk and
be unfiltered and yeah the point of
Megan's podcast is that you're hearing
more of her in her own words I I think
Megan continues to divide opinion and
she's a bit like well Mike you love her
or you hate her but certainly through
her podcast I think she's wanted to use
her voice so that people have the
opportunity to hear her views on certain
things her struggle with certain labels
that she feels and have sort of
polarized her through throughout her
career and throughout her life so I I'm
not necessarily sure it's one hurt an
army of new fans but I think people are
tuning in out of curiosity if nothing
else and and certainly for Megan it's
giving her an opportunity to talk about
some of the labels she feels have often
in case has been unfairly person on her
but William and Kate and the children
it's actually been a period of just
trying to get some normality back into
their lives they've moved to Windsor
after the summer holidays the children
will one day into their new school
lambrook school in Windsor when the
queen died and of course their lives
were turned upside down so I think the
past few weeks have really just been a
about getting into that school routine
and making the most the term before the
Christmas holidays turn up and then
really making sure that they're going to
enjoy that time as a family the Wales is
traditionally go to animal Hall in
Norfolk that's where they spend their
Christmas that's not far at all from
Sandringham and they will be together as
a family for Christmas at Sandra and I
think that's going to be very important
to the king important that this is his
first Christmas as the king important
that he's continuing the tradition loved
by his mother and started by the queen
and of course this will be the first
year that we have King Charles III
addressing the nation with his very
first Christmas broadcast as king
foreign
[Music]